every day it seems there's a new
bewildering or frightening story about
AI in the news how it's going to steal
our jobs spread internet fakery on a
colossal scale and generally take over
the world but what exactly is AI
artificial intelligence and are the
scare stories even
true five things you really need to know
about
ai ai is as old as your
grandparents so so the first thing to
know is that AI has been around a lot
longer than you might think its roots
lie in an idea known as an artificial
neural network from the
1940s a neural network is a bit like a
team of interconnected workers that
learn to solve problems each time they
come up with a possible solution it's
marked if there's room for improvement
they adjust and change their connections
over time the network becomes more
efficient and Technology powered by
neural networ NW works is all around us
right now it suggests movies and music
we might like it recognizes faces and
objects when taking photos on
smartphones enabling features like
facial recognition it's heavily used by
social media platforms to personalize
our feeds more recently a form of AI
known as generative AI is powering
applications that can seemingly create
new data it can also power chat Bots
like open AIS chat GPT and Google's
which give humanlike responses to
questions these are getting better at
interacting with us and seemingly more
humanlike this can seem scary but it's
worth knowing point two hey I can't feel
or
think if you ask chat GPT a question
like this one why should we be concerned
about AI it does a pretty good job of
providing a response that appears
logical and with that convincing
humanlike response it's easy easy for us
to believe it understands what it's
saying that it has feelings and
motivations it's understandable that we
do this but it's worth remembering right
now ai can't think or feel can't love or
hate chat GPT and its counterparts are
sophisticated sentence completion apps
that analyze our patterns of
communication and provide responses
similar to the way humans would
typically reply a bit like a talking
parrot which leads us to point number
three AI make stuff
up chat Bots can have an awkward
relationship with the truth technically
known as AI hallucinations you could
also describe it as making stuff up the
core of the technology is a model that
uses probability to predict the next
word sentence or paragraph it can
generate seemingly plausible replies but
lacks the ability to assess truthfulness
or the accuracy of its responses so
anyone thinking of using chat Bots to
run right content needs to be careful
they're not incorporating credi sounding
BS that could be easily spotted by
someone who's actually done the
research AI can sound racist and
sexist the idea of a racist machine
might seem far-fetched but if AI is
trained on data that's racist biased or
hateful then its output will be two as
we all know racism bias and hateful
content can be found in abundance online
in 2016 Microsoft launched an
experimental chatbot called tay but
quickly pulled the plug after it made
racist and offensive remarks it learned
to do this from interacting with users
on social media Microsoft apologized and
promised to implement improved safety
features in future this is why the
ethical framework that governs any AI
application is incredibly important and
why many are calling for safeguards to
prevent bias and hate speech to be built
into AI systems AI has incredible
potential for all the notes of caution
it can be easy to forget as many
potential benefits to AI it's set to
truly revolutionize Healthcare AI has
already discovered new drugs and is
being used to identify cancer cells much
more reliably than humans and AI
chatbots can behave like patient
teachers When we struggle to understand
a complex topic summarizing huge volumes
of information for us the AI revolution
has the potential to enhance and speed
up work in many fields from software
programming to animation to law
enforcement and journalism this has
pluses and minuses of course but could
this extra capacity free us up to do
other things like tackling climate
change or looking after ourselves and
each other
better as AI advances governments and
Regulators will of course need to make
sure it's being used ethically and
legally no easy feet but will AI take
over the world don't forget AI is a tool
and even a powerful tool can't take over
the world on its own it's up to us to
decide how we use it or even if we
should use it at all thanks for watching
if you enjoyed that be sure to check out
these videos next and if you haven't
already hit the Subscribe button and
click the Bell to get a notification
each time we upload a new video